in this video you're going to learn how
to work with similar figures and how to
find the missing side length or the
missing area or the missing volume we're
going to go through three examples so
let's dive into this video let's first
talk about just a simple example so you
kind of understand what exactly are
similar figures similar means they're
basically the same shape but not
necessarily the same size what I mean by
that is like say if you take your
smartphone and you do one of these deals
where you're enlarging something or
reducing something you don't distort the
shape it's still the same shape you
recognize it but it's proportionally
larger or smaller so the corresponding
angles would stay the same so for
example if I had a square these angles
would all still be right angles so again
it's not distorting it it's just making
the uh corresponding sides
proportionally larger or smaller by a
scale factor and what we can look at
here is imagine if we had these two
squares and we say well what's the
what's the ratio okay or the scale
factor well you can see that the ratio
of the corresponding sides is 2 to six
which we could write it as a fraction
like a 1/3 okay you can also write it
with a colon like 1 1: 3 like that or
you can even write the word two in
between 1 to three that's the ratio
between the two sides but let's say we
wanted to find the uh perimeter of this
Square well the perimeter we know is the
distance all the way around if we add
all those sides together we could say
that the uh perimeter here is equal to 8
the perimeter here is 6 + 6+ 6 + 6 which
is 25 4 and notice that the ratio of the
perimeters 8 over 24 reduces to 1: 3 the
same as the ratio of the sides the way I
like to think about that is the
perimeter is really just like a string
that's tied all the way around this
object and it's really just represents
length or like a onedimensional a line
is like 1D right onedimensional
but if we look at the S length that's
also onedimensional it's just like the
length so it makes sense that the ratios
would be the same now if we look at the
area of this smaller Square 2 * 2 or
side time side or side squared gives us
an area of four square units here if we
do side times side that gives us an area
of 36 now notice the ratio of 4 ID 36 is
reducing to 1 nth now you might say well
wait a second I thought the scale factor
was 1/3 well if you multiply let's say 6
* 1/3 you get 2 and 6 * 1/3 you get two
and we no area side times side so it's
you know this side's 1/3 less or 1/3 of
this this side's 1/3 so 1/3 * 1/3 is 1
nth so when you're comparing the ratio
of the areas you want to take that scale
factor and square it the way I like to
think about it is I think of area is
two-dimensional it's length by width
right length is just onedimensional so
if I take that scale factor and square
it I'm going to get the ratio of the
areas okay and if we want to take this
one step further let's imagine instead
of these being squares that they're
actually cubes we're dealing with
threedimensional object here and let's
just say that it's uh 2x 2 x two 6X 6X 6
here the volume would be 2 * 2 * 2 is 8
here the volume is 6 * 6 * 6 which is
216 8 divid 216 reduces
to
127th okay and you'll notice that's 1/3
not squared but cubed because if you
think about got it the length is 1/3 of
six the width is 1/3 the height is 1/3
so you have 1/3 * 1/3 * 1/3 or 1/3 cubed
the way I like to think about it is
three-dimensional volume right it's 3D
it's the scale factor to the third power
now I just want to show you a little
table here just to kind of help solidify
this idea for you and we're going to get
into the three example problems in just
a second I promise uh but just so you
understand this real clearly the scale
factor remember that's kind of like
onedimensional the perimeter that's like
onedimensional area we said is like
two-dimensional volume is like
threedimensional so if they give us the
scale factor and they say oh it's a 1:
two is the ratio between the sides right
the ratio of the perimeters will also be
the same 1 to two the ratio of the areas
we'd have to square this 1 squar is 1 2
squar is four so it's a 1: four ratio
and the volume is going to be the scale
factor uh cubed so one cubed is 1 and 2
cubed is8 so we have a 1 to8 ratio
between the volumes but say they give us
the perimeter now and we say hm how do
we find the scale factor well the ratio
of the perimeters is the same as the
scale factor comparing the sides that's
also going to be 3 to 5 if we do the
area we have to square the scale factor
because we're going from onedimensional
to two-dimensional right so we're
squaring this so 3^ squ is 9 5^ s is 25
and if we're going to for the volume
that's threedimensional we're going to
cube the scale factor 3 cubed is 27 5
cubed is
125 so that's the ratio of the volumes
and we can make a proportion I'll show
you how to do that in these examples but
let's look at this one here they're
giving us the area which is comparing
the two-dimensional objects we want to
compare just the scale factor the ratio
of the corresponding sides so to go from
the area to the scale factor we're going
from two dimensional to onedimensional
we're going to actually have to take the
square root okay see the difference the
square root so squ of 16 is 4 squ of 81
is 9 and the ratio of the perimeters is
the same 4 to 9 because perimeter and
the scale factor they're both
onedimensional but to go from the scale
factor to the ratio of the volumes we're
going to have to cube this see we're
going from one D to 3D 4 cubed is 64 9
cubed is
729 that's the ratio of the volumes and
lastly if they give us the ratio of the
volumes threedimensional we're going to
take the cube root to get the the scale
factor comparing the one-dimensional
components cube of 27 is 3 cube root of
a 1000 is 10 cu 10 * 10 * 10 is a th000
once we have the scale factor we know
the ratio of the perimeters it's the
same 3 to 10 and we can find the areas
the ratio of the areas by squaring that
scale factor 3 squ is 9 10 s is 100 so I
hope that makes sense let's dive into
some examples you'll see how this works
the symbol for similar is this guy right
here and it basically tells us that the
shapes are the same size but one's
proportionally larger or smaller than
the other one if they give us these two
areas but we want to find this missing
side length remember area is
two-dimensional we're going to have to
take the square root to get the ratio of
the one-dimensional components the sides
square of 49 is 7 sare of 4 is 2 and I'm
going to make a proportion here now see
if you can follow this notice seven is
larger than two so I'm comparing the
larger object here on the left the
smaller object on the right so I say
large to small that ratio is the same as
large to small here we know that the
larger object on the left has a side
length of two this side length we don't
know let's just call it X proportions we
can cross multiply to solve so we can
say hm this diagonal multiplied together
7x is equal to this diagonal multiplied
together 4 divide both sides by seven
and you can see X is equal to 47 that's
how long this side length is but the key
here is to kind of ask yourself am I
given the
two-dimensional uh information or the
three-dimensional information or the
onedimensional and where am I going am I
going from in this case from two
dimensional to onedimensional right I
had to take the square root if I was
going from one to two I'd have to square
or raise it to the second power let's
look at number two now here we're given
these pyramids and let's just say that
they're similar okay meaning that you
know they're proportionally larger or
smaller all the corresponding angles are
congruent but we're given the volumes
and we want to find this missing side
length well volume I know is
threedimensional right 3D how do I go
from the volume the threedimensional
ratio to the ratio of the side lengths
which is just onedimensional well to go
from threedimensional to onedimensional
I have to take the cube root right so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
write this as a fraction 125 over 8 and
I'm going to take the cube root of that
what number times itself 3 * is 125
that's five what number times itself 3 *
is 8 that's two and notice I'm comparing
large to small five is bigger than two
so large to small large to small see now
I can compare the corresponding sides
cross multiply 5x is equal to 4 * 2
which is 8 divide both sides by five and
you can see X is coming out to 8 fths
and that's the missing side length but
again remember we're going from 3D
threedimensional Volume to
onedimensional that's that's why we had
to take the cube root to get the ratio
of those sides that scale factor let's
do one more example see if you can do
this one on your own and we'll go
through it together see if you can do
this third example we're given these two
stars okay and they're similar to one
another and we're given this side length
is six and this side length is two this
area is 100 how much is the area of the
smaller star so how would you do that
one and while you're doing that problem
I'll do it uh we can check it together
just want to let you know about my
courses if you haven't uh gotten them
already I've got an algebra 1 and
Algebra 2 video course I've got links in
the description below check those out
they're really helpful if you like the
way that I explain things but what I
notice here is that we're comparing
these one-dimensional components it's
like a ratio of 6 to2 right which can be
reduced by dividing these by two so it's
a ratio of 3 to one but notice we're
comparing the side lengths which is
onedimensional we want to compare the
areas which are two-dimensional what do
we have to do to the scale factor well
if you said Square it you're absolutely
right so we're going to square this and
that's going to give us a ratio of the
areas of 9 to one right so the other
thing that students sometimes have a
little bit of a challenge with is they
don't know what to put in the numerator
and in the denominator and you can do
this a couple different ways you can say
I'm going from left to right see 6 to2
that's uh 3: one so left to right and so
I'm comparing the left object to the
right object the area of the left object
is 100 the area of the right object we
don't know we'll call it X the way I
like to do it is I like to look get the
ratio here and say 9 to one nine is
obviously bigger than one so I'm
comparing the larger object to the
smaller object I have to put the area of
the larger object up here and the
smaller down here large to small large
to small then we can cross multiply
cross the uh equal sign there cross
product 9x is equal to 100 * 1 which is
100 divide both sides by 9 and you can
see we're getting X is equal to 100 over
9 is the area of this smaller star so
great job if you're able to all these
examples if you want more practice which
I highly recommend it's good to practice
these test yourself follow me over to
that other video I did talk about
talking about similar figures see if you
can pause the video and try some of
those examples and master this concept
I'll see you over in that video